say no say no say
[Music]
okay so I have an idea
um it's November and everyone is already
celebrating Christmas well I've got a
special outfit for Tyler to have I
didn't know the toilers I closer to the
door a good idea what didn't get wait no
um can we uh can we have you wear this
thing what is it it's a costume sorry
what the hell am i doing in this
freaking koster you can't talk your
turkey say say it
say the thing gobble gobble okay
somebody asked me what we do I just did
ask again what the hell am i doing in
this costume they're not your real voice
yeah that's right that's not your real
voice talking really how am i doing in
the sky no no no no your oil boys what
are you talking stop putting on an
accent just say boys why you so insecure
about it yeah man come on you don't have
to be afraid you're on friends peach
it's a safe place here mom hates you boo
come on come on no yes Clem line please
oh this is what I do for you guys I'm
forced to do this gobble gobble so we're
just leaving Target we were gonna do a
funny bit in there with Tyler in the
turkey costume going around and shopping
for Christmas stuff we're gonna have a
lot of good footage there but then
target security came over in like three
different people from or like you can't
film here don't do that you absolutely
cannot um which is fine it's there right
I'm not gonna criticize their right to
refuse us to film there but it's also
within our right to list all of targets
competitors so here they are
gobble gobble gobble gobble gobble
gobble gobble gobble gobble yeah gah bah
gah gah gah gah gah gah gah gah gah gah
gah I know we're all angry at Target but
we need to channel our energy to make
the best sketch possible what's got you
asked gobble
[Music]
I
ha
okay
gobble gobble gobble gobble gobble
go
oh yeah ketchup oh hello
you do really
that's me cool oh that's awesome yeah
did you like it
you late like that yeah Oh what do you
think is costume yeah really
oh happy Thanksgiving it say the fing
Tyler see it's a novel gobble